viele haben gehofft dass die antwort auf
dieses rätsel den schlüssel zum
universum enthält das informations
paradoxon von schwarzen löchern gehen
informationen in schwarzen löchern
verloren obwohl das im rest des
universums eigentlich unmöglich ist das
problem steht stellvertretend für die
tatsache dass die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie und die
quantenmechanik die beiden fundamentalen
regelwerke unserer physik noch immer
nicht zusammenpassen
jetzt nach jahrzehntelanger suche sieht
es so aus als ob eine lösung für das
informations paradoxon gefunden wäre
doch ist das wirklich der große
durchbruch und wie war das möglich
nun man braucht nur ein paar wurmlöcher
ein paar string theoretiker und einen
großen haufen kranken
m access ist riesig
vorher werde es darin die information
dass kam der haupt- und ist keine vision
you don't use of physics dieses video
wird unterstützt von jpm jpn
einzurichten ist kinderleicht und
erlaubt euch das internet so anzusteuern
als würdet ihr in 60 ländern überall auf
der welt gleichzeitig sein
ich bin zum beispiel ein riesengroßer
fan von age bio serien wie west world
sex essen oder auch game of thrones bis
auf das ende aber die ersten staffeln
lohnt sich auf jeden fall zu gucken
das problem ist nur dass man hier in
deutschland leider kein age bio gucken
kann aber mit nord bpm kann ich
problemlos mal eben nach schweden oder
nach norwegen wechseln und über e on
nordic all diese serien anschauen und
wenn man schon mal dabei ist dann lohnt
sich auch ein blick auf das netflix
angebot außerhalb von deutschland zb the
good place ist ein super geile serie die
man in den niederlanden gucken kann und
das alles ohne abstriche bei der
videoqualität
die bedienung geht super einfach am pc
kann man sich eine browser erweiterung
installieren und das ganze geht
natürlich auch per app auf dem tablet
oder smartphone und bis zu sechs geräte
gleichzeitig und das beste ist mit dem
doktor watson bekommt ihr einen monat
komplett gratis wenn durch ein 2 jahres
paket holt und falls ihr noch nicht
überzeugt seid habt ihr danach nochmal
30 tage zeit das sich anders überlegen
und ein komplettes geld zurückzubekommen
nord wie pr.com / doktor watson oder
beim checkout doktor watson ich weiß in
der quantenwelt erscheint einem
eigentlich alles paradox aber das
informations paradoxon steht für ein
ganz spezielles problem aber das schon
seit jahrzehnten debattiert wird
da gibt es einmal das team gravitation
die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
besagt nämlich dass alles aber auch
wirklich absolut alles was einmal den
sogenannten ereignishorizont eines
schwarzen lochs überschritten hat auf
nimmerwiedersehen in ihm verschwindet
denn hinter dieser gedachten linie ist
die raum krümmung eines schwarzen lochs
so groß dass ihm nichts mehr entkommt
nicht einmal legt deswegen heißen
schwarze löcher auch so wie sie heißen
dann kamen stephen hawkings theorie die
erlauben es immerhin das aus einem
schwarzen loch energie wieder
herauskommt das ganze nennt sich hawking
strahlung und ist im prinzip eine kleine
menge energie strahlung die das schwarze
loch laut hawking abgeben müsste
theoretisch würden die meisten löcher
deswegen auch irgendwann verdampfen also
irgendwann selbst ein kleines schwarzes
loch wurde dafür wahrscheinlich so lange
brauchen wie unser universum gerade alt
ist information kommt über die hawking
strahlung aber nicht heraus sagte
hawking der zu dem zeitpunkt mehr oder
weniger zum team gravitation gehörte das
team information stimmt dem aber nicht
zu denn laut den gesetzen der
quantenmechanik kann informationen
niemals verloren gehen sondern bleibt
über alle zeit erhalten
das grundprinzip dahinter ist eigentlich
recht simpel weil ich aus dem jetzt
ableiten kann wie die zukunft aussehen
wird kann ich aus dem jetzt auch
ableiten was in der vergangenheit mal
passiert ist der la blanche der mann
dafür muss ich nur alle informationen
über dem jetzigen zustand haben denn in
der quantenmechanik wird der zukünftige
zustand immer vom jetzigen bestimmt er
folgt quasi aus ihm und mit bestimmten
mathematischen operationen kann man dann
dementsprechend auch zurückrechnen okay
lass mir die quanten mal kurz beiseite
denn die können jetzt nicht kompliziert
sein und erklären das ganze mit etwas
ganz normalem wie zb diesen ball hier
den kann ich nämlich fallen lassen jetzt
kann nicht voraussagen dass er
irgendwann auf dem boden aufkommen wird
umgekehrt weiß ich aber in dem moment in
dem er auf dem boden aufkommt auch das
er vorher gefallen sein muss
ich habe also informationen über seinen
vorherigen zustand und ich kann sogar
noch weiter zurück gehen daher von
irgend etwas runter gefallen sein muss
weiß ich das irgendwann vorher hoch
gehoben worden sein muss und weil man
das theoretisch immer weiter rückwärts
machen kann geht die informationen über
den zustand seiner quanten teile also
was und wo der ball einmal war niemals
verloren so die theorie das gleiche
müsste demnach auch gelten wenn ich in
ein schwarzes loch hinein falle das ist
zwar sehr ungemütlich aber wenn eines
schönen tages die einzelnen quanten aus
denen ich jetzt gerade bestehe über die
hawking strahlung wieder herauskommen
dann müsste man eigentlich zurück
rechnen können dass das einmalig war
laut dem team gravitation geht genau das
aber nicht denn laut ihnen ist ein
schwarzes loch
undicht dass alles darin noch drei
eigenschaften hat eine masse eine
elektrische ladung und einen drehimpuls
alle informationen aus denen man mich
rekonstruieren könnte sind für immer
verloren und das ist paradox warum kommt
die materie über die hawking strahlung
wieder heraus aber nicht die information
das ist das informations paradoxon es
ist eines der relevantesten paradoxer in
der physik weil sich die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie und die
quantenphysik hier widersprechen also
ist eine von beiden womöglich nicht
korrekt oder wir wenden sie nicht
richtig an
vielleicht ist die grundlage unseres
universums dann nicht einmal die
raumzeit eines der fundamentalen
konzepte der physik die forschenden
hoffen dass die lösung des informations
paradoxon es auch dieses problem löst
und beide theorien miteinander vereint
und damit kommen wir zur frage aller
fragen die frage deren antwort hinweise
darauf geben kann was die grundlage
unseres universums ist welches der
beiden teams hat recht ist gravitation
so mächtig dass sie sogar informationen
zerstören kann
oder bleibt informationen auf immer und
ewig erhalten egal was ist okay
zuallererst die beiden teams haben sich
schon länger angenähert doch das
grundproblem blieb in den berechnungen
wurde die entropie des schwarzen lochs
also die menge der informationen die wir
nicht haben immer größer wie bei hawking
die sache mit den profis ein bisschen
komplizierter die muss man sich ein zwei
mal verdeutlicht ein bisschen wirklich
sinn ergibt es gilt je kleiner die
entropie desto mehr wissen wir und hier
größer die entropie desto weniger wissen
wir also immer umgekehrt
laut hawking wird auch die verschränkung
entropie eines schwarzen lochs immer
größer das ist eine besondere form der
entropie mit der angegeben wird wie
stark quanten miteinander verschränkt
sind in unserem fall die quanten in und
außerhalb des schwarzen los bevor ich
aber erkläre warum das ein schlüssel zur
lösung des paradox ist hier noch mal
ganz kurz was verschränkt eigentlich
bedeutet und wenn ihr das ausführlich
erklärt bekommen wollt wir haben für
euch die vielen verrückten phänomen in
der quantenwelt in einer ganzen
videoreihe mal erklärt danke ich nochmal
viel ausführlicher auf diese dinge ein
die playlist dazu findet ihr hier oben
unter dem
aber zurück zur verschränkung wenn sich
zwei quanten miteinander verschränken
ist das ein bisschen so als würden sie
zu zweigen zwillingen werden
sie nehmen dann immer exakt
gegensätzliches pins an ich bin ist eine
quanten eigenschaft die man sich am
besten wie eine drehrichtung vorstellen
kann
wenn ich also vereinfacht gesagt die
drehrichtung eines teilchens ändere dann
ändert sich die seines zwillings seines
verschränkten teilchen es ebenfalls und
zwar sofort egal wie weit die beiden
auseinander sind
es geht so weit dass sich die beiden in
einem schwarzen loch kennenlernen
könnten und eines reichs mit der hawking
strahlung wieder heraus es bleibt aber
trotzdem mit seinem zwilling verbunden
wenn wir es jetzt in einer weltraum
kneipe zum beispiel abpassen könnten
dann könnten wir an ihm ablesen welchen
zustand sein zwilling im schwarzen loch
jetzt gerade hat doch wir wussten
natürlich nicht dass es einen zwilling
im schwarzen loch gibt da habe ich
wirklich alle informationen im sinne der
quantenmechanik erst wenn beide
verschränkten quanten wieder draußen
sind
das ist wie wenn ich auf der straße zum
beispiel einen ohrring finde
vermutlich gibt es einen zweiten und
vermutlich sieht er genauso aus wie der
erste
aber wirklich wissen tue ich das erst
wenn ich beide ohrringe habe
das heißt die verschränkung saint tropez
muss wieder 0 werden wenn wir alle
unsere informationen zurück haben wollen
sie dürfte nicht endlos steigen wie die
verschränkung saint tropez bei hawking
eine idee wie die verschränkung saint
tropez wieder 0 werden könnte würde also
helfen das informations paradoxon zu
lösen
john cage ein schüler von hawking hat in
den 2000er jahren eine kurve
vorgeschlagen bei der genau das möglich
ist die sogenannte page kurve und das
ist jetzt mal ausnahmsweise etwas das
durch einen ausflug in die quantenwelt
mehr sinn ergibt als vorher
laut page folgt die verschränkung saint
tropez eines schwarzen lochs einem
umgedrehten v zur geburt des schwarzen
lochs ist sie noch 0
logisch denn noch ist dem loch ja fast
nichts also auch keine informationen und
keine verschränken quanten dann wächst
das loch und je mehr nun über die
hawking strahlung wieder heraus kommt
desto größer wird die verschränkung
saint tropez und desto mehr
informationen haben wir vorläufig an das
schwarze loch verloren
das ganze geht so lange bis wir einen
zeitpunkt namens page time passieren
der wahrscheinlich in der mitte oder
nach zwei dritteln der lebenszeit eines
schwarzen lochs liegt ab dann sind die
quanten in dem schwarzen noch so sehr
mit einer
verschränkt das quasi keine mehr übrig
sind die noch alleine sind
das ist jetzt sehr bildlich gesprochen
und mathematisch betrachtet müsste man
das eigentlich etwas anders formulieren
aber der vollständigkeit halber sei
diesmal so also liebe physiker bitte
verzeiht mir und mit wem sind die
quanten dann verschränkt genau mit
quanten dies über die hawking strahlung
heraus geschafft haben
und je mehr quanten nun frei werden
desto mehr zwillingspärchens sind wieder
frei die verschränkung entropie nimmt
also ab wir haben unsere informationen
wieder und die quantenmechanik und das
team informationen sind glücklich aber
warte mal ist das informations paradoxon
also eigen schon seit über 20 jahren
gelöst
leider nein wenn diese page kurve konnte
bisher nicht nach konstruiert werden und
genau das hat sich jetzt gerade geändert
gleich zwei wissenschafts teams konnten
die page kurve nachweisen um das
paradoxon zu lösen hat jeff pennington
von der university of california tief in
die zauberkiste der mathematik gegriffen
er simulierte matrizen wo wurmlöcher ein
und versuchte die unendlichen
bewegungsmöglichkeiten eines quanz
einzuberechnen
ein ganz wichtiges konzept seiner arbeit
sind die so genannten quanten extreme
allen oberflächen kann man sich so ein
bisschen vorstellen wie die außenwand
einer seifenblase
es gibt einen drinnen und draußen sowie
beim schwarzen loch in unserem fall
wissen wir
vereinfacht gesprochen über das drinnen
des schwarzen lochs einfach gar nichts
und über das außen und das universum
quasi alles
das wollen wir mit hilfe der
verschränkung der quanten und der page
kurve natürlich ändern
daher können wir die menge an
informationen die wir über das innere
des schwarzen lochs haben mit der
verschränkung saint tropez angeben
und es gilt wenn ich die oberfläche der
seifenblase berechnen kann dann weiß ich
wie groß die verschränkung saint tropez
ist denn die oberfläche ist immer so
klein wie möglich mit hilfe der quanten
ex gemahlen oberfläche wird also unsere
verschränkung saint tropez und somit
auch die menge an verlorener und
wiedergewonnener informationen
berechenbar
die erklärung der genauen mathematik
erspare ich euch an der stelle mal ich
glaube es genügt zu sagen dass ihre
beschreibung setzte involviert wie das
ergebnis ist ein sattel punkt der
multiple schwarze löcher verbunden durch
die raumzeit wurmlöcher enthält oder
auch ein klassiker weil die strahlung
eng mit dem schwarzen loch verbunden
ist der quantencomputer ist auch
computer und schwarzes loch sind also
quasi mit einem wohnblock verbunden
ich habe es nicht geschafft aber auf
jeden fall kam heraus die verschränkung
saint tropez teilt sich sowie die page
kurve als vorausgesagt hat sie stimmt
also eine forschungsgruppe rund um ahmed
al marri vom institute of advanced study
in princeton new jersey hat darauf
aufgebaut und an einem konkreten modell
mit zwei dimensionen die page kurve
durchgerechnet für die unter euch die
mehr wissen wollen es geht unter anderem
um ein modell dass leds cft heißt und
sich einige effekte der stringtheorie
zunutze macht das ergebnis war erneut
die page kurve stimmt schwarze löcher
geben also informationen wieder her
das informations paradoxon könnte damit
gelöst sein
das ist aber natürlich noch nicht das
ende der geschichte
jetzt beginnt der vielleicht noch
größere teil der arbeit die berechnungen
müssen von anderen forschenden überprüft
werden
und was dabei rauskommt ist weiß
natürlich noch niemand manche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
denken dass jeff pennington zu viele
annahmen und vereinfachungen gemacht hat
und seine ergebnisse nicht korrekt sind
die berechnungen von ahmed al marri
wiederum wenden nur zwei dimensionen an
anstatt 4 auch wenn die rechnungen auch
für vier dimensionen gültig bleiben
müssten
und wie genau die information aus dem
schwarzen loch wieder heraus kommt das
weiß auch noch niemand doch im gegensatz
zu den schlagzeilen der letzten jahre
dass das informations paradoxon endlich
gelöst sei wird es langsam tatsächlich
konkret sagt professor daniel grumiller
theoretischer physiker von der
universität wien
man hat nun hinweise dass die
informationen über die
quantenverschränkung zwischen der
hawking strahlung und den quanten im
schwarzen loch wieder heraus kommt und
an einem vereinfachten modell konnte das
ja sogar schon berechnet werden es sind
nur teilschritte aber alle gehen in die
richtige richtung
dennoch wird es noch ein langer weg bis
wir endgültig sagen können das
informations paradoxon ist definitiv
gelöst
einige forschende sind auch frustriert
von den beiden präsentierten lösungen
denn sie haben das eigentliche geze
nicht wirklich entschlüsseln können sie
hatten gehofft dass die lösung des
paradoxon es endlich eine der größten
fragen der heutigen physik beantwortet
die quantengravitation den punkt indem
die allgemeine relativitätstheorie und
die quantenmechanik noch immer nicht
zusammenpassen wollen
vermutlich ist also eine der beiden
theorien an einem grundsätzlichen punkt
irgendwo falsch und wir wissen trotz all
unserer formel noch immer nicht welchen
gesetzen unsere realität wirklich folgt
die neuen berechnungen behandeln
gravitation auf jeden fall immer noch
sowie einstellen sie beschrieben hat
hier gab es eigentlich keine
bahnbrechende neuerungen als fan der
physik kann es echt frustrierend sein
auf jeden fall haben die neuen
berechnungen aber weitere hinweise
darauf geliefert dass die raumzeit nicht
die grundlage unseres universums sein
könnte physikerinnen und physiker
vermuten schon länger dass es noch etwas
anderes geben könnte das uns allen zu
grunde liegt das wird hier mit nur noch
wahrscheinlicher die beiden projekte
sind also vor allem der beginn von noch
viel mehr spannender forschung
hoffen wir mal dass wir das alles noch
miterleben werden es wäre ja schon im
mikro- oder so eine formel die alles
beschreiben kann die weltformel würde
dir dazu eigentlich gerne mal ein video
sehen schreibt mir gerne mal in die
kommentare ich habe zum beispiel gelesen
dass der erfinder von wolframalpha der
mathematik website da was spannendes
gefunden haben will dass mich eigentlich
ganz gerne mal überprüfen und was wir
auf jeden fall machen werden ist ein
wissenschaftler reagieren auf inters
teller
da geht es ja auch um wurmlöcher um
schwarze löcher und gravitation und ich
wollte mal wissen ob das auch alles
wissenschaftlich korrekt ist was sich
der liebe christa von nolan da
ausgedacht hat es lohnt sich also den
kanal zu abonnieren und die glocke zu
aktivieren damit ihr nichts verpasst bis
dahin bleibt neugierig patrick und ich
verschwinde jetzt in ein schwarzes loch